[Music]
the latest paper in nature thus four of
us as authors does myself
Yanis bit sakis he's been responsible
for deciphering the inscriptions on the
mechanism and he has made a major
contribution John Steele expert on
ancient astronomy and Alexander Jones
very distinguished historian of ancients
astronomy I heard of the research line
was invited to the conference in Athens
where the new results were presented
publicly and they were quite dazzling
really not only was there a clear
consensus of how the gear work in the
mechanism worked for the first time but
also there was the new evidence of a lot
of new text inscribed on the surfaces
inside fragments on the outside surfaces
of fragments we knew there was text but
much more was being read and it was
clear that there was going to be much
more work to be done there this was very
exciting the process by which we read
the month names on the metonic dial was
very much about and forth between Tony
Freeth and myself he would send me by
email of images that were made by his
tomography software and these would be
like very very thin slices made through
a fragment of the mechanism and we had a
really exciting exchange of emails where
I was giving him new information about
bits of text I'd read and he was doing
the reverse and I being completely
ignorant of ancient Greek astronomy
couldn't interpret this but alex was the
ideal person to actually interpret and
understand what we were reading the
names of the months on the mechanism are
very valuable for us because they
identify possible places where the
mechanism might have been manufactured
possibly where the mechanism was meant
to be used possibly both we can't be
sure now this is a great surprise for us
all expectations were that the mechanism
would have come from someplace in the
eastern Mediterranean perhaps the island
of Rhodes that has been the most popular
candidate what we found was that the
calendar is characteristic of places
that are
always in the western part of Greece up
in the northwest of Greece or the island
of Sicily one of the possible places
that had the same calendar that the
mechanism had on the metonic dial was
Syracuse Syracuse was a great city of
the Greek world it was also the hometown
of one of the greatest of ancient
mathematicians and scientists Archimedes
there is a quote from Cicero in the
classical literature which describes a
mechanism that was made by Archimedes
that sounds very similar to the
Antikythera mechanism so it's very
tempting for us to link the mechanism
with Archimedes but Archimedes was
killed at the siege of Syracuse in 212
BC we think the earliest this mechanism
could be as a hundred and forty BC so we
don't think Archimedes made the
mechanism but there is a possibility if
it came from Syracuse that it was made
as part of a workshop tradition that
goes back to the great old mill another
thing we discovered was that the machine
is an eclipse prediction machine it has
a dial which follows this ancient
Eclipse prediction cycle called the
Saros cycle if you have an eclipse in
one month and you look 223 months later
you will get a very similar clips
whether it's of the Sun or the moon and
this repeat goes on for 12 or 15th
centuries it's a remarkable cycle to
show you this one this is sort of from
inside and I'm going round through an
ass to show the cero style this is the
serous eclipse
datian dial here you sit and you have to
reset it obviously this little dial here
which is we call the excellent mas dial
goes around once every just over 54
years it's a triple sarah so every time
you go round this dial you go run one of
these sectors the numbers in these
sectors tell us how much time to add to
the Eclipse time in the glyph when we go
round this dial for a second time for
etter and a third time here it's a
diagram it's a little our adjustment so
we now know what the function of this
little dial is as well it's beautiful
isn't it another small dial stars in the
latest nature paper the Olympiad dial
was a very exciting part of our work the
dial you can see in this slice it's the
circular ring with two crossed diameters
but this slice is a bit too high up to
show you very much writing on it now
Tony was sending me slices they were
running down from here you see details
that don't show up in the first slice
you can see some lettering is showing up
here this is the Alpha like in modern a
now I'm showing the lettering inside the
pie slices that show the key cycle of
your numbers so in every year of the
cycle there would be one or two of these
international games held and the
mechanism is showing for the current
year which are the games to expect a
four year cycle is a bit of a surprise
on the mechanism because it doesn't
really have an astronomical function it
has a cultural function it was the
timing for the games that the Greek
cities organized in major cult centers
at four-year or two-year intervals like
the Olympic Games which are not events
of any scientific significance but
they're events that were of enormous
social significance in the Greek world
and now darling was put all this
together and actually make his replica
Antikythera work
[Applause]
but his most famous instrument the 14th
century Dandi clock this is the dial of
the Sun shows just what he can do
I'm astonished by this you know if you
think 14th century I just you know
that's the full Ptolemaic system for the
planets isn't it yes yes see when I see
this I see the development of the
antique it's our technology you do those
all there as its birth in the antique
its realism and then you see this
extraordinary evolution into the
Ptolemaic system what we have now is a
mechanism which is as price said a
mechanical calculating machine it
calculates cycles of the solar system
and it does it in a beautiful and
brilliant way prices model was a
complicated model doing simple things we
have a complicated model doing
complicated and extremely sophisticated
things in a design which is pure genius
it is falling at the top level of what
we know that ancient Greek science could
do and ancient mechanical technology
could do I sit for days looking at these
x-rays and I find these tiny little
clues about how it works and what it did
and I'm still astonished by it
you
you
[Music]